[Music]
we begin with the latest from
afghanistan where at least 47 people
including a prominent cleric have been
killed in a bomb explosion it happened
during friday prayers at the biggest
mosque in the western city of harat
witnesses say the pro-taliban cleric
mujib rakhman ansari and his group were
on their way to the mosque no one's yet
claimed responsibility for the attack
let's speak to latfula luth who's an
afghan journalist and political analyst
he joins us now live from kabul uh good
to have you with us what more do we know
about this attack and who might have
been behind it
the information that i have is the
official information is that 18 people
have been killed and moving from people
have been injured together
in the western city of herat
in afghanistan
as far as the question of who might be
behind this attack so far someone is
just to claim the responsibility for the
attack
but there are different dynamics and
different complications that one can
talk about
this is not the first time that a
religious scholar is the target of such
attack in the last few years any
religious father who had enjoyed the
broadband
support
across afghanistan in different parts of
afghanistan or who were like the
supporters of the government these
the previous republic of today's the
islamic community afghanistan there was
the
potential targets of such attack
it was a societal attack so um
apparently
maybe it may make a claim may claim
responsibility for this
but it is yet to be known
and what does it say uh for the
prospects of peace and security in
afghanistan when such a high profile
figure could have been targeted like
this
well this is the continuation of the
garam saga uh that has been going on in
afghanistan for so many decades
the famous author olaf koeri in his book
deepak said that unlike other wars you
war in other words in afghanistan
get uglier when they are over so i think
it is one would be under a illusion to
think and claim that there is full place
security
uh across afghanistan that the people
can enjoy
this is the indication that we are
there is much more to come unfortunately
in at the end of the day it will be the
people of afghanistan the ordinary
people who will suffer so it is not i
think over yet
and i'm sad to say that the prospect is
not
is not good
and and yes there are some people who
are entitled to to driving the picture
of the future but as far as i understand
the dynamics the indications
are such that
we will be having a future ahead
what about the timing of this particular
attack though is that significant
uh the timing is also significant
because on the one hand the taliban are
claiming that now there is uh
security across running sign that people
have don't have to worry but on the
other hand if you say you see that this
profile that
which which claimed the life of a
high-profile religious rutaliban
religious scholar is i think that they
feel this will kind of detest or even
also contest the the claim that taliban
are making
so and also there are some internal
dynamic problems
the the the situation afghanistan which
is now under sanctioned by the usc by
other countries so this is i think rpd
complication
uh and also i think it's going to turn
precarious more and more
good to talk to you lord follow me
thanks indeed for being with us lord
fuller luther in kabul